depuis sa création il ya dix huit ans
l'association et ses péages de la
possibilité aux personnes porteuses de
handicap de développer et d'exploiter
leur savoir faire autour d'activités
sportives et culturelles associations
sportives culturelles et la persuasion
ce risque
nous avons créé ça parce qu'il ya
souvent isolés donc c'est pourquoi pas
une association qui vont travailler avec
plusieurs partenaires pour essayer
justement d'amener ces personnes à
sanctionner pour trouver un bien-être la
vie quotidienne voilà pourquoi la
sottise
les membres de l'association s'apprête à
s'envoler pour la métropole afin de
participer au concours national handed
ans
une rencontre qu'il prépare depuis
plusieurs moins avec des l'cie beaudry
chorégraphe de danse indienne
c'est une rencontre un coup four qui
rassemble plus d'un millier de danseurs
en situation de handicap tous handicaps
confondus
et donc c'est chouette est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir découvrir la diversité des
danses puisque toutes les disciplines
sont représentées on va trouver tous
types de danse avec le groupe d'adultes
de l'ess et bh on prépare deux
chorégraphies ça fait que quelques mois
est-ce que je les ai rencontrés l'année
dernière et j'ai commencé aussi à créer
avec marie-claire un diu avec son élève
ce sera donc en fauteuil pour
marie-claire la danse est une véritable
passion qu'ils l'aident à combattre son
handicap
ça nous permet aussi de ce fameux
c'est une nouvelle corse parce que quand
on
ensuite la musique adoucit les moeurs
ensuite nous ça c'est universel
sur le court n 6
et
[Musique]
là je pense que pratique de la danse
pour financer son voyage l'association
organisé diverses collectes mais a
également bénéficié des des
collectivités telles que le département
[Musique]